some surrounded by a protective membrane
which makes it difficult for viruses to
get inside them HIV is an enveloped
virus surrounded by a similar membrane
that is able to fuse with the cell
membrane the envelope glycoprotein of
HIV is performs the steps needed for
membrane fusion the env glycoprotein is
found on the surface of HIV inform swabs
may put three identical subunits the end
is covered with carbohydrate and is
encoded in the HIV genome as one long
protein the glycoprotein has been very
difficult to study because it is covered
in flexible carbohydrates it is normally
bound to membranes and it is naturally
flexible researchers have solved this
problem by cutting off all the flexible
and sticky parts and just turning the
rigid cord molecule the immune system
looks for foreign molecules in the body
but the HIV virus has learned to
disguise itself as a human molecule
making all the more difficult for our
immune system to find and destroy when
viruses make their surface glycoproteins
in infected cells they camouflage
themselves with same sugar chains that
coat the proteins of humans which makes
it hard for antibodies to reach these
viruses have error-prone replication
machinery which means that once the
immune system has found antibodies to
recognize the infecting virus other
viruses rush to rapidly mutate to chain
to the site that is recognized so the
immune system cannot destroy them
antibodies focus on molecules on the
viral surface that are bound to the
envelope glycoprotein this is a problem
because one the virus can quickly evade
the antibodies and two the antibodies
are attacking the surface which is not
essential for function of the virus
after some time fighting the HIV
infection some people develop broadly
neutralizing antibodies termed broadly
because they attack many strains of the
virus and neutralizing because they
attack key functional sites in the virus
and block infection
unfortunately however these antibodies
usually come too late and do not provide
effective protection above the disease
researchers are trying to make the
immune system create these broadly
neutralizing antibiotics quickly through
the use of a vaccine researchers have a
daunting task of creating this
life-saving vaccine but while it is in
development it is important to get
tested for HIV